ah valerian champions tour has
officially ended well we have our
winners we still have a bunch of
questions will emea keep its crown next
year will na recover from a devastating
defeat next year what exploit will riot
spend 20 minutes researching to make
sure it's legal
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring that notification bell if you
don't
there'll be no in-person vct tournaments
next year which would suck so
hop to it
folks we made it after a long year that
included roster changes upsets dynasties
created and whatever this was you saw
cass the flank's so good here does he
decide to go for this now
the first year of the valerian champions
tour has finished and boy did we have a
hell of a conclusion ascend took home
the very first trophy what was a
thrilling champions tournament that if
nothing else showed us that bellerin is
no one regents game we had some drama
which i already talked about in another
video but just in case riot is watching
this
this camera is illegal since slowly
making their way into the site the
camera is going to get all of the
information from joe this jump is not
so glad we had that talk riot every
region has a huge stake and as of right
now has the skill to win it all which
makes the valet competitive scene the
most exciting that it can be but of
course before we get into c netting
companies when we gotta rewind and talk
about what we learned this tournament
which i can do for you because i watched
every bit of it just from the master
circuit to champions so many teams
demonstrated major improvements and made
a name for themselves in this tournament
which a lot of people thought would be
very predictable
which it wasn't for example sca's team
secret after enduring so much showed the
world that they are forced to be
reckoned with and made their way all the
way to the quarterfinals while team
secret did not make it to the semifinals
they had such an impressive run and
that's with the altso otto buff there
are many haters out there that they told
us that they we can you know we can win
at least one map against teams from
vct we just proved them that you know we
made it to the playoffs and you know
prove them wrong and i would be remiss
if i did not mention the goliath of crew
esports who took down sentinels furia
fanatic and very nearly took down gambit
in what was a truly heartbreaking
overtime in the semis that truly was
anyone's match and it proved that crew
is now a fan favorite that teams should
fear like gambit or sentinels and also
can we talk about kezmit for a second
that literal 6k he got on icebox
equalize things a bit off of those two
weapons but they've got to be successful
and durka's bladestorm finds none plant
walls down there it goes here into doma
the team's set up a bit of a defense
already flank is being watched by mystic
as well
just is able to mow them down they're
sitting ducks they can't find any room
to breathe that's kaznit says you didn't
get the ace dark up a baby i did i said
it on twitter and i'll say it again
keznet has godlike aim and god like game
sense that kid is absolutely incredible
i think kesnet had a pretty
insurmountable task of becoming a known
duelist in this tournament full of known
duelists like we know about cnet we know
about scream we know about durka but
then here comes keznet
rising to the task and outshining them
all arguably and he played reina not jet
which kind of sets the meta tone he was
like hey what if i play reina maybe some
rays and some breach on fracture and
also cypher at one point like what
he's just a different player he's clutch
he's smart he has like really good
decision making with his utility on
raise which a lot of races don't and i
think that's what separates a plot and
he's also like really good at like
finding the first frags and getting out
and of course x10 crit who provided the
world with the definition of upset
proves to everyone that if you doubt
them
you should do your research start with
my body is still going strong in the
back side down through the cloud first
it comes to bladestorm but it's not even
needed scary closes it out and sca are
going all the way to playoffs envy have
been eliminated in tandem with this
another thing we learned is
throw out your expectations especially
early in any sport sentinel's out before
quarterfinals it's more likely than you
think in fact it actually happened they
lost to crew it sucks we were all sad
dude i could tell it affected the guys
everyone really cared
as much as people think we don't care
for the narrative that n a doesn't care
or care about streams or whatever i
promise like i know our team tried
really hard
and we felt really good about it going
in we practiced a lot we had everything
drilled rehearsed i did a lot of prep
we just didn't deliver we've heard some
rumors about some roster shuffles and
things won't be confirmed for a little
bit but things are changing the na game
plan is changing of course we need to
talk about our underdogs our dark horses
our world champions ascend they won it
all after loki flying under the radar
for
everyone
it's reassured possession
what zeke two kills out of nowhere and
suddenly this round becomes a little bit
more viable but time is the biggest
problem oh my word zeke is this when
you're to step up and deliver but it's
going to be chronicle the body
the timing i don't think he's going to
have the time surely
surely no way oh my god zeke has just
destroyed them their path to the finals
was capped off when they low-key
destroyed team liquid in the semis on
saturday like team liquid were one of
the favorites coming into this
tournament and what we watched was a
literal buffet for ascend with dessert
and remember team liquid were on a
winning streak when they met ascend and
had just beaten them at red bull home
ground i guess the brother buff only
goes so far
or link's bald buff ascend eventually
met the masters three champions gambit
and after a very very close map four
brought it to map five and eventually
won the entire thing nats is on the
other side of this but all he has is
that specter he's already seen one pass
cnn finds one it's all on red car now
and this is what it comes down to one
more man to stand and red guard 30
seconds left all the hours you've put in
thousands upon thousands is down to a
1v4 and it's done ascend are your
ballarat champions winners
ascend had the nickname cned and friends
even coming into this tournament but
here they proved that they can work as a
cohesive unit and take it all of course
cned kind of has now this like colt lake
status because he's the epitome of jet
diff but all of ascend zeek helis bone
cold star so they all solidified their
champion status on sunday also we got
this cnet photo which like i literally
have never seen cnet act like that
before so
cool we all knew how good cena is but it
was really awesome to see the whole team
meet and then beat my expectations and
hopes for them in the winner's press
conference they chalked it up to their
mental coach but
damn ascend look crisp i think what
makes ascendant just so good is like i
said like they're playing [ __ ]
compositions that are like old
compositions like beta conversations
they're playing omen and brimstone no
astra they're winning with it and i
really think that i really think the
reason why they're winning is because
they're so alpha so confident they just
think they're the best team i think what
makes this win even sweeter is seeing
them so emotional after their win and
celebrating a hard-fought victory with
such joy and elation you know when you
can tell someone has worked so hard for
what they've achieved
that was that moment so ascend are our
champions they have proven to teams
across the world they are forced to be
reckoned with
now what well we have a new vct format
but first a gift guide we partnered with
our friends over at predator gaming to
give you a lovely holiday gift guide
you'll get to know us host a little bit
better and find out what we're all
looking for this holiday season and
maybe get some gift ideas for yourself
because the holiday season is upon us so
all right folks you heard liz we've
teamed up with our friends over at
predator gaming to bring you a little
holiday gift guide you've probably
already heard from some of my friends
who host other shows already but
basically we're gonna tell you what we
want this holiday season and maybe we
can give you some ideas of what to ask
for for yourself so let's get started
the pandemic is finally ending and i'm
really excited to finally get to travel
again and one of the things i'm most
excited about traveling to is fighting
game tournaments that's why one of the
things i want most this holiday season
is the snack box micro look i have a ton
of fight sticks actually i have so many
that i don't know where to put all of
them but one more can't hurt right and
at least this one is so small that it
looks like it fits really easily into a
suitcase look traveling with bulky
steaks was one of the only annoying
parts about going to fighting game
tournaments so getting a stick that
looks easy to pack sounds awesome and
not to be greedy but while we're talking
about traveling i'd really like a way to
play games on the go and i think i know
exactly what i'm looking for look we all
want a steam deck i know i'm not being
original but this thing looks like it
rules getting to play my entire steam
library anywhere means i might finally
work my way through my giant stupid
backlog anyway you can probably tell i'm
all about traveling again which means
i'm gonna need a new laptop luckily our
friends over at predator gaming have
just what i'm looking for with the
predator triton 300se like i said i'm
looking for a sleek and powerful laptop
that i can stick in my suitcase since
i'm trying to spend as little time at
home as possible next year so a thin
easy to carry laptop with an intel 11th
gen h-series core i7 processor and 9
hours of battery life that's good for
work and gaming is exactly what i'm
looking for this holiday season i'd
recommend checking it out at your local
best buy
[Music]
good stuff friend uh where were we
new vct format so basically next year
this is what it will look like two
masters and champions is being moved to
september quote each challenger split
will see a single open qualifier that
will lead into multiple weeks of play
between top teams and finish with a
large tournament to crown a single
victor and qualified teams for
international masters competitions also
we finally have an international
tournament circuit for game changers so
we get to see if anyone can take down c9
white which if champions has taught us
anything
probably there are no guaranteed winners
or
best teams it's it's pretty cool annie
is ready which is cool and terrifying if
you're facing her in addition to this in
a press release riot said quote finally
riot games will launch a new additive
tournament series that will take place
between vct seasons
working with the best third party
operators ride games will create a
lineup of new events that will allow for
both existing and new players to
showcase their talents to make sure that
these capture the intention of the
entire valorem fan base events will not
overlap with each other and will take
place between bct seasons so you yes you
better get to practicing i want to see
you kick some butt in these tournaments
okay
there are region specific announcements
so if you're interested in your or
another specific region head to the
official valor and esports news site for
more information if you're confused look
at this pyramid better basically you've
got to work your way up the ladder some
teams like team liquid and ascend for
ema are already invited at challenger's
stages so what it looks like to me is
there's more opportunity in the 2022 vct
season and valerian themselves called
the 2022 navct the uh quote n a
redemption tour on the site so uh
there's that as i was writing this
script there were roster changes and
format changes and it was literally the
day after champions ended like not even
24 hours after the final map so if
you're not excited about next year's
competitive season
are you good hello hello
hello ascend are our champions but as
valerie themselves put it when they're
writing about the 2022 vct season
heavy is the head that wears the crown
ascend aren't afraid though they can try
this will not stop us you know from
still growing as a team and as players
and it will not
affect you know
our gameplay negatively definitely for
the next season and we will fight for
our title again from the very first
teams forming to now it's kind of hard
to believe that valerian has only
finished its first competitive year
it feels like it's been five
i asked raucous look back at this year
and this is what he said it's really
similar because like i did it in
overwatch too right it's good to start
in the scene and watch it grow as a
whole because at the very beginning i
didn't have many years and stuff like
that it wasn't as big then it got so
much traction hype and hype and hype and
now it's like to the point where we
literally just had a million viewer
final it's like it's getting really big
and it's super exciting to be involved
with a scene that's so popular and
bride's new baby you know their new game
i think a lot of growth has occurred
when the game first came out and that
like constant cs go comparisons or just
the game is easy to encourage no skill
and it's really nice to see a game come
into its own at such an early age so
at the end of the day all this it is
just super exciting to think about
what's going to happen next year
and maybe just maybe knock on wood
we will all be in person where we can
just
scream and shout and enjoy the game
together
or i wish i was like popper things like
yay
gamers if you will
it's a cli bomb
but not good enough
also just his insight like super chill
dude super smart also he is such a cute
dog he has the cutest dog it's so cute
hurt she's so cute because she's like
this oh she's so cute the first time i
met raucous
he turned on his camera and i saw him
and then i saw his dog so i went hi oh
my god who was that and he was so
confused you know i felt so bad but i
got so excited to see his dog